we decided to go to Hawaii because we
heard about this Mark Zuckerberg story
where he was suing Native Hawaiians for
land that they owned and as we did more
and more research we realized this is a
very complicated thing but this is a
really important story to tell from
there we got connected to a bunch of
folks and learned about sort of a
thriving sovereignty movement that stuff
is going on there and realize wow that's
a really important story to tell as well
so I had never been to flying which I
think in hindsight after this tragic is
a blessing because I'm just like all
these other Americans who are guilty of
you know in the past having saying oh I
need a vacation we could go to Hawaii
you know so many of us fee it is just
like this pristine beautiful paradise we
can going to lay on the beach and
whatever and I was really surprised and
humbled and almost ashamed to learn so
much about their political history I had
no idea that they used to be a sovereign
Kingdom it was overthrown by the United
States that pain that they experienced
is still very much present it's like a
collective generational trauma almost so
many people we tossed and called it a
deep wound so to go there and to hear
about how their history really resonates
with a lot of reporting we've done on
indigenous folks in the US and on
Palestinians you know currently fighting
settler colonialism this is still very
much an active story in Hawaii so I'm
glad that having gone there the first
time I experimented and heard it first
anthem from actual Hawaiian
[Music]
the most memorable moment that we had in
Hawaii was when we went to one of the
charter schools you know throughout the
whole time we were in Hawaii I was very
interested in in how the history of
Hawaii was taught to Hawaiians and what
was really disheartening to find out
with a lot of Hawaiians saying like we
didn't grow up learning it either we
didn't really necessarily we weren't
taught that in Justices that happened
when America took over Hawaii there was
this calculated campaign to basically
decimate their history and their culture
and their language to the point where
they even banned them from speaking
Hawaiian into school and so it was
really powerful to see these charter
schools which were sort of formed as an
answer to this whitewashing of the
education system because like this are
very important for our community here in
Hawaii because it offers us access to
cultural knowledge cultural practice
cultural intuition that was purposefully
and systematically oppressed they're
really instilling the history and
culture and stuff in these kids and so I
just wanted to know like what's your
experience you know why did you choose
to go to the school how do you think
it's different than other schools and
they were woke there were some woke high
school kids and they're like you know
here they actually teach us real life
skills and they teach us the history and
I was just at an international
conference where you know we learned
about the occupation and why it's
illegal under international law and so
you know I think that the aim of these
charter schools is to create a
generation of Hawaiian youth that will
then sort of lead this push for
sovereignty to not forget the Hawaiian
history and to reclaim their identity
and reclaim their land and it's also
important to remember that they're free
these charter schools are free
so many people would tell us you know
everyone tells us get over what happened
it happened it's in the past and what
the Hawaiians would tell us it is still
happening you know we're still losing
our lands like Zuckerberg is just the
latest example but he's by no means an
exception they're struggling financially
you know Hawaiians are poor people not
very much rich Hawaiians are do that and
they can't even afford their own lands
that you know billionaires and
millionaires here from the mainland can
go buy up even though some of them have
ancestral claim to it they're kuleana
lands that we reported on in the first
story Hawaii is not a state it is still
a sovereign Kingdom you're listening to
kicking CR Hanalei ka q8 Kilauea I'll be
right back
we visited this radio show in Kauai
called songs of sovereignty and the
radio show host Kai was talk to us in
saying you know Hawaiians since
basically the Americans came here in the
1800s we've been in a position of
servitude and we continue to be in a
position of services today Hawaiians
really don't own their land most of us
live in our cars or are very close to
living in our cars as we put that
coconut bra on to go to work I would
hope that anybody watching this video in
this series really takes that away and
thinks about the context of a place and
the people that live there and that are
from there you know if they go visit and
not just have like the vacations left
hey everyone it's Deena make sure you
check out our entire Hawaii series and
let us know what you think in the
comments and tell us where you think we
should go next